faites moi un dussollier spécial jacky
aussi les mains le fait - roland giraud
à la troc a fêté à ce monsieur
faites moi un couffin n'ai pas d'enfants
dans ces conditions tant pis faites moi
un boujenah je vous préviens monsieur je
ne le serai jamais sans accent mais
pourquoi un bruit très vivant vraiment
ah voilà monsieur par michel boujenah
bonsoir bonsoir art est venu en bateau
la wii qu'est-ce qui pilote le bateau le
capitaine a bâti ce n'est pas le
capitaine du bateau
ah non il vaut mieux pas sur le
propriétaire non plus ah bon ces paniers
en bateau alors mon bateau est plus
petit a fait capitaine un grand bateau à
moi c'est moi le capitaine mais c'est
moins dangereux parce que votre est
beaucoup plus petit quand je range mon
bateau au port
et bien qu'ils soient très petits en
général ça dure au moins une demi-heure
et un général j'ai toujours tous les
types qui ont des bateaux au tour qui me
donne des conseils ce qui fait que ça
devient une catastrophe or une salle du
mal avec les créneaux beaucoup beaucoup
surtout parce qu'un bateau ça bouge tout
le temps et on n'a pas aimé ça freine
pas vu donc c'est l'enfer père faisait
là ça va pas encore mais ça commence à
aller mieux
ah oui je devais aller j'ai arrêté le
théâtre à trois semaines et j'en pouvais
plus en plus physiquement j'étais au
bout du rouleau
d'ailleurs ça se voyait
j'avais même du mal à jouer en même
temps c'était c'était une aventure
pleinement forte du jury 185 fois dans
l'année et c'était beaucoup quoi
beaucoup trop alors tu as laissé ta
maison de saint paul de vence la seule
en beau oui hein c'est ça fait pas le
choix cette maison à peine utile at il
commence déjà à les piquer nom est très
bien sûr ça fait deux ans que mémé avant
quand je jouais des maisons j'avais du
mal à partir parce que je savais que
c'était fini
et là elle est là ça fait qu'elle est là
elle est pas loin elle est là et je sais
que si chez moi il est à toi dis c'est
la première fois que je pose mes valises
oui ça y est la taton oui c'est chez moi
c'est vraiment chez moi c'est drôle
parce que je me souviens d'un copain qui
est venu au tout début quand j'ai
commencé un qui m'a dit la location se
termine corps alors cette maison tu l'a
rêvé tu l'a dessinée tu en as surveiller
la construction
oui et tu as dis je me suis saignée aux
quatre veines pour l'acheter oui elle a
compté faire comme tout le monde ça
c'est pas important c'est à dire plutôt
que la vendre je préférerais repeindre
les appartements nuitées jour jean ce
que certains dé appartenait déjà les
jours avant déjà fait c'est ce que c'est
ah oui tout à fait j'ai déjà fait j'ai
fait plein de trucs comme ça avant ouais
je n'aimerais pas et en même temps si si
pour la garder il faut que je fasse des
choses que j'aime pas ouais ou une
manière de travailler que j'aime pas eh
ben je la vendrai a quand même oui il ya
trop de gens qui ont sacrifié leur vie à
des choses comme ça et dans mon métier
j'ai vu des gens comment dire avoir des
besoins avec le succès l'argent tous à
avoir des besoins puis tout d'un coup
avoir un peu moins de succès avoir les
mêmes besoins et commencer à faire
n'importe quoi et a plus travaillé comme
il avait envie de travailler
tout ça pour garder les conséquences du
succès je dirais c'est à dire le pognon
et et ça je pourrais pas quel serait le
pire pour toi comme chose à faire que je
supporterai pas vraiment tu dirais
suivant la maison ça serait quoi
par exemple une émission de télévision
être animateur de télévision par exemple
préfèrent la maison et ça risque quand
même arriver parce que c'est vrai ça
m'arrivait parce que je pourrais pas
faire un c'est impossible
je suis trop nul pour ça ah oui tu crois
quoi ah oui oui je pourrais pas dans ça
se regarde pas si oui non peut-être
encore plus que certain émoi pourquoi
saint paul de vence à l'heure je suis
tombé amoureux pas sa place et comment
belge allait jouer à nice et puis on m'a
emmené des jeunes et la colombe d'or et
j'ai regardé en roulé puis je regardais
cet endroit je dis qu'est ce que c'est
beau puis j'y suis revenue
quinze jours après passer un week-end et
puis j'ai dit tiens je vais répéter la
alors j'ai trouvé une salle de
répétition à nice et j'ai répété
l'ange-gardien là bas et puis j'ai
commencé à connaître des gens je me suis
senti bien c'est à cinq minutes de la
mer c'est à dix minutes de l'aéroport
tout est prêt pas loin de paris c'était
simple et puis j'ai eu un coup de chance
formidable j'ai trouvé un endroit ce qui
est très rare
j'ai eu un coup de chance incroyable
c'était un coup qui s'étaient disputés
au parce qu'il ya des gens fait que
c'est fou parce que les maisons c'est
flou il ya des gens ils deviennent fous
en construisant des maisons
voici la ville existait déjà à non non
non avant c'était des gens qui avaient
le terrain et il devait construire une
maison ils se sont disputés sur les
plans ils sont tellement différents
qu'ils ont divorcé
dis moi papa était tenté d'acheter une
maison en tunisie pourquoi tu as acheté
à saint-paul maintenant chez moi c'est
ici
c'est quoi le premier lieu pour toi qui
est associé à l'idée de vacances et quel
endroit où la tunisie quel endroit
un endroit qui s'appelle crédit à côté
de pas très loin de la goulette
on avait une espèce de petite maison de
vacances comme un peu tu sais comme les
cabanons près de marseille mais dans ce
genre là en fait avec une terrasse sur
la mer et fouet c'était le paradis
toutes les façons de comme tous les
comme tous les enfants qu'on a arraché
un lieu d'enfants où il était bien
j'essaye de reproduire partout
les sensations que j'avais quand je me
souviens de vacances en grèce où j'ai
passé mon temps et mes copains il me dit
mais tu es fou pas si longtemps dira
tiens ça c'est comme à tunis à tiens ça
c'est le boulot de tunis ah tiens ça
c'est le blanc tunis à tient aujourd'hui
me suis baigné comme à tunis
vous allez soutenir le grand allemand de
vacances j'aime pas parler ma vie mais
il ya une histoire qui est drôle qui est
arrivé c'est que kim a afrique images
pas en parler maintenant parce que ça
fait ya prescription
c'est que mon premier flirt elle était
plus vieille que moi alors bon on s'est
embrassés je ne savais pas mais on s'est
débrouillé jeu c'est de faire comme je
voulais dans les films et puis mes
frères on avait raconté comment on
faisait à peu près et puis évidemment
j'ai essayé de lui enlever son soutien
gorge et j'ai jamais réussi
elle ne m'a jamais dit ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui ce genre de situation
m'arriver je dire écoute gens pouvaient
d'au moins une paire de ciseaux de la
rage
mais la juge michon je n'arrivais pas je
savais c'est un enfer j'ai passé
l'après-midi sur le soutien gorge sur
loon la fermeture en plus est comme ça
m'a tellement traumatisée je suis devenu
un champion du monde scanner alors tu
séjour un tous les soutiens gorge avec
une main parce que j'ai passé après
après cette histoire
chaque mois je passais devant un magasin
de lingerie je regardais tous les pianos
et je regardais comment ça s'ouvre et
j'essayais de mémoriser et après c'est
devenu un jeu chaque fois que j'étais
avec une fille jeu
j'essaie de toucher le pjd range
derrière et je vous paierai l'ouverture
ginestas et ça c'est un numéro 4 et
j'ouvrirai dis moi tu as ouvert de
chansons de qui tombe qui ont marqué t&t
à william une chanson comme mon père
tenait tout le temps tournait s'était tu
m'as fait tourner la tête
mon manège à moi mon manège à moi ça et
puis et maintenant de gilbert bécaud que
vais-je faire ça ça me plaisait beaucoup
je m'étais souvent mais tu sais c'est
surtout
des odeurs des moments la pêche par
exemple nous ont péché est aujourd'hui à
plus de poisson pour faire ça on prenait
les toiles de sacs de pommes de terre
en toile de jute beige la comprenait de
la mie de pain on mettait ça depuis avec
la friture qui arrive et on va basculer
son entrée oloron pêcher à la bouteille
tu prends une bouteille comme comme ça
un peu mais comme ça mais incolore et tu
casses ici et tu m'as un bouchon ici à
chennai ouais il fumait de l'eau de mer
et de l'ami matin et tu es tu là mais
c'était interdit et on mettait la
bouteille palau en la regardant à
surveiller on n'a pas fait des petits
mulet comme ça et il fallait apprécier
des mulets femelles pourquoi ben comme
ça allait mal arrive c'est pareil
déchaîné wallon et je vous rappelle
qu'en général les mâles je me tairai pas
le cas je sais pas comment mais pour les
poissons c'est comme ça